Hey Bojack. You ever meet any
Boston celebrities?
Well, one time at Bristol Farms,
Ben Affleck and I did reach
for the same bunch of grapes.
Oh, he eats grapes just like us?
Hey, Ma,
Ben Affleck eats grapes.
He don't eat grapes!
BoJack said
he fed Affleck grapes.
He was graping it up
with the Daredevil himself.
-This is the greatest day
of my life.
-(GROANS)
Hey, I don't suppose you boys
would have any interest
in maybe playing some
touch football later?
Are you kidding? Touch football
with a star like you?
That would be mad wicked pisser.
Ooh, you know what else
we got to do?
We got to watch
the Cryane video.
-(LAUGHS)
-Ooh, that sounds good.
What's that?
No, we don't need
to revisit that.
When Deedee was 16,
we made up a secret pen pal
for her named Leo.
-(LAUGHS)
-Guys...
We all took turns
writing her letters,
pretending to be this
sensitive boy from Cambridge.
It was wicked messed up.
"Oh, Diane,
we're two misunderstood souls.
Everyone else is a phony.
Yours forever, Leo."
-(LAUGHS)
-What?
After six months of letters,
we hired a homeless guy
to pretend to be Leo
and take her
to the homecoming dance.
-MARTY: Look at her.
-GARY: Watch, watch this part.
-I like your boutonniere.
-(LAUGHTER)
(CRIES)
GARY:
Why don't we watch this
every day?
-Look at her face.
-Now that's a good prank.
I was humiliated.
Yeah, you wouldn't get it.
It's a brothers thing,
right, brothers?
(LAUGHTER)
You know,
it's nice that years later
we can all laugh about this.
Yep, my therapist
thinks the same thing.
I'm gonna go meet
with the funeral director.
Any of you boys want to come?
Nah, I ain't so big
on funeral homes, Deedee.
All them dead bodies,
they give me the jeebies.
Yeah, Deedee,
why do we got to go?
Fine, none of you have to go.
I'll take care of everything.
Thank you, Diane.
We all really appreciate it.
Come on, BoJack.
Why you got to take
BoJack with you?
-Boo! Boo!
-(BLEATS)
Boys, you have stolen my heart
like Dave Roberts
stole second base.
Hey! He knows our things!
I must go now,
but I'll see you all
at the funeral, okay?
And when I do,
you're all getting noogies.
-Funeral!
-Yeah!
ALL: Funeral! Funeral! Funeral!
♪ (CHURCH MUSIC PLAYING)
Tell me about your father.
Well, he was a mean,
sadistic alcoholic,
who never supported
anything I did,
and actively delighted
in seeing me fail.
Hmm, I see.
Sounds like you're looking for
our Piece of Shit Dad Package.
That would be too good
for my father.
Might I then suggest
our Piece of Shit Dad Package
Would Be Too Good
For Him Package.
Yeah, that's the one.